Welcome back.
So these sessions cover a really
tough period for the party of
Beast Bond, a companion's death
on Mount Gaffes, A tragic
accident and then a very
deceptive return to Valaki.
The groundwork here is
fantastic.
I mean, it shows these brutal
consequences of failure.
Now we just need to look at how
to maximize the, you know, the
lingering impact of it all.
I agree completely.
The material is strong, really
strong, especially in how it
generates these high stakes
failures.
Yeah.
But our job here is to make sure
those failures don't just happen
to the characters, but that they
that they inhabit them.
We're talking about maximizing
that narrative reverberation.
OK, so let's begin where I think
the greatest emotional taxes
due, but the payment was kind of
summarized away.
Right, and here's the core idea.
The true horror and significance
of major setbacks can be
deepened by actively detailing
the immediate emotional cost
rather than summarizing the
transition away from the
tragedy.
And we're talking about two
massive events here.
First, Truxador's brutal death
by the rocks on the mountain.
Yeah.
And then later, the crushing
accidental death of the maiden
after that cart disaster.
Both are inherently dramatic,
but after these defining
traumas, notes just indicate the
party moves on almost
clinically.
Exactly.
If we look at the notes after
the maiden's death, it literally
says the party simply turns and
continues on their way.
And after Tracidor's cremation,
they only take an hour
recuperating before they just,
you know, make the strategic
decision to descend.
That immediate detachment, that
quick back, it really risks
minimizing the gravity.
It's almost like a kindness to
the characters, but it's a
cruelty to the drama.
It really is.
It turns what should be a
defining moment of tragedy into
just another waypoint on the
map.
Right.
If the characters bounce back
instantly, the reader doesn't
feel that loss.
We're left asking, did that even
hurt?
So the problem isn't that the
characters don't care, it's that
the notes, by just summarizing
the action, skip over the
necessary emotional processing.
It's a pacing choice that kind
of deflates the consequence.
We need to force them to pay
that emotional tax.
And that tax is the story here.
But how do we dedicate that
space without, you know,
grinding the story to a halt?
They do have to keep moving.
Well, my suggestion is to
dedicate focused, specific space
to the characters immediate
reactions, coping mechanisms, or
just the subtle manifestation of
trauma, even if it delays the
next plot point by a few
narrative breaths.
OK.
The descriptive quality that was
used for Urihorn's mystical
bonding with the Mountain Lion.
That intimate sensory detail
that needs to be applied to
these moments of distress.
If they can write peace
beautifully, they have to write
pain just as beautifully.
That makes sense.
We're not adding a chapter on
therapy.
No, we're adding a paragraph of
sensory detail that carries the
weight.
So let's start with the Maiden's
death on the road.
OK, so instead of them just
turning away, maybe we note how
the scene affects the character
with the most agency in that
moment, Radley.
The Eldritch night.
Right, He let the cart pass him.
Exactly.
He carries the heaviest burden
of responsibility for that
disaster.
So you focus on a specific
horrible detail suggests that
the sound of the girl's screams
seems to linger, you know,
echoing off the trees even after
the sound of the impact has
faded.
That's powerful.
It turns a physical sound into
an internal psychological scar.
Precisely.
Or you could describe a shared
heavy silence between Yurihorn
and Dermont as that he struggled
to process their failure to
catch the cart.
That silence, you know, against
the gruesome scene, it speaks
volumes.
It's the quiet shame of not
being fast enough.
And what about on the mountain
after Tracidor's cremation?
That's a totally different kind
of trauma, almost cosmic.
We just shift the sensory focus
there.
We lean into the physicality of
the grief.
Mention the lingering acrid
smell of burning flesh, not just
ash, but the undeniable scent of
their friend.
Or describe how the physical
exhaustion causes the party to
move slower, literally dragging
their feet through the snow.
You make the consequence
manifest in the environment.
Yes.
That physically represents the
weight of loss on the journey
back down, making the trauma
part of their bodies, not just
their thoughts.
When you make the reader feel
that physical toll, you maximize
the cost of the sacrifice.
That focus on the immediate
burden leads right into how they
handle the similar pressure
point later.
Moving from that horror on the
road to the village we hit that
crucial deception scene with is
Mark.
Yeah.
Which carries its own kind of
moral weight.
And this brings us right to our
second opportunity.
The significant decision to
deceive is Mark about Arena's
true fate offers an excellent
opportunity to inject profound
narrative tension into an
otherwise straightforward scene.
I mean they don't tell is Mark
the church was burned, the
priest was killed, that straw
demanded Irena.
Or that the mob surrendered her.
A terrifying mob.
Yeah, they just say they left
her at the church and moved on.
The lie of omission is just
monumental.
And the weakness is that the
reporting of this betrayal is,
well, it's flat.
It reads like a factual account
of what was said instead of a
tense, high stakes moment of
coordinated lying.
It makes the moral betrayal feel
too easy.
And it's made worse by the scene
right before it is Mark is so
paranoid that he douses them in
holy water to make sure they're
not undead.
Exactly.
That test establishes immediate
paranoia, but the dialogue that
follows doesn't really leverage
it.
Precisely.
Right now, it sounds easy to lie
to a grieving, desperate man who
has just shown he doesn't trust
them.
This is a moment where they
cross a moral line, and the
notes just have to reflect that
weight.
The reader needs to be leaning
forward, terrified they'll get
caught.
So the suggestion has to be
about reframing it as a
performance.
Absolutely.
My suggestion is to frame the
interaction not just as a
factual report of the lie, but
as a delicate performance where
every verbal omission and
partial truth is loaded with the
danger of discovery.
This shift would highlight the
mental gymnastics Radley and
Derman have to do while facing
this desperate Ismark.
They aren't just answering
questions, they're improvising
an alibi under extreme duress.
So how do we translate that
internal performance into
readable action?
What does that high wire act
look like on the page?
You focus on the sensory
details, on the physical
discomfort of the liars.
Describe the effort it took for
Radley and Dermont to maintain
their composure.
Dermont the arcane trickster.
He's usually quick witted, but
here he has to measure every
single word.
Maybe he pauses too long before
answering.
Yes, or he avoids ismarks Eye
contact.
That internal pause, described
well, transmits the tension
directly to the reader.
And you could contrast their
state with Ismarks to heighten
the stress.
You have to you contrast the
intense urgency of Ismarc, who
is pressing, pressing them about
his sister, with the overly
controlled, almost rehearsed
answers of the party.
Maybe Radley, disheveled and
exhausted, struggles to hold a
serious face.
Describe the physical pain of
forcing that mask on.
That immediately raises the
stakes.
We move from just omitting facts
to actively performing a denial
of trauma, which is so much more
dramatic it builds massive
narrative irony.
And that irony is the ticking
clock we have to highlight, the
palpable relief mixed with
immediate guilt when is Mark
finally accepts the story and
rushes off.
Right.
That dual emotion relief.
It worked.
And guilt over the betrayal?
It shows the emotional burden
the lie imposes on them.
And by making that relief
explicit, you emphasize that
this omission will have
consequences.
It's going to hang over them
just waiting to explode.
OK, now let's circle back to
Mount Gehacas.
Because the failure to reach the
Amber Temple and losing Trxador,
it needs a better sense of
closure.
We talked about the emotional
toll, but what about the
physical arc of the retreat
itself?
And that brings us to pacing.
The crucial transition phase
following the intense rock
battle and the failure to reach
the Amber Temple requires
deliberate pacing to fully
register the severity of the
loss and the strategic necessity
of retreat.
The weakness here is structural
compression.
The notes summarize the retreat
from Selinka Pass way too fast.
After the death in the battle.
It jumps from searching an empty
tower for fuel to just a simple
summary.
They again climb over the wall
and then journey back down.
It compresses what should be a
grinding, painful withdrawal
into just a few quick lines of
text.
Yeah, and this rushes past the
physical and psychological toll
of abandoning their mission.
It leaves the weight of tracidor
sacrifice feeling less
impactful.
The reader needs to feel that
Mount Gehacas rejected them.
Isn't just the rocks, it's the
mountain they couldn't conquer.
That's it exactly.
The mountain has to remain an
active antagonist even after the
demons are defeated, so the
suggestion is to expand the
description of the retreat,
making sure the action
emphasizes the physical
difficulty, the unrelenting
cold, and the psychological
impact of failure.
We need to make the mountainside
feel like it's still trying to
kill them.
So if we slow down, how do we
keep the descent from just
becoming a tedious travel log?
Instead of summarizing, you
focus on the sheer mechanics of
the retreat, the contrast
between the adrenaline of the
fight and the grinding
exhaustion afterward.
Detail the the precariousness of
climbing down those rigged ropes
with fingers that are stiff and
frigid.
You highlight the effort
required to help the less agile
party members.
And you reinforce that earlier
description, the evocative one.
The notes mentioned the climb up
was like a monkey trying to fuck
a football.
Right.
That image should be amplified
here.
Show that same struggle, but now
it's compounded by exhaustion
and grief and defeat.
That grinding effort is
magnified when they know they
are running from a failed
mission, not moving toward a
goal.
And the cold is such a constant
threat in this section, but it
fades once the summary starts.
That sensory input has to come
back.
It absolutely has to, and a good
way to pull that threat back in
is to use the character Bond as
a yardstick.
Mention how the Mountain Lion or
a horns new bond navigates the
descent.
OK.
Lawyer the cat scrambled up a
near vertical surface, showing
its strength.
You contrast that early strength
with the current fatigue.
Maybe the Mountain Lion moves
slower now it's fur icing over,
or it struggles for a moment to
keep its footing on the ice
covered switchbacks over that
precipitous drop.
That small detail about the
animal struggle would instantly
symbolize the party's own
fatigue.
It grounds the failure in
something tangible and makes the
environment the final,
relentless obstacle.
By applying the physical weight
of that failure to the descent,
the reader gets the time they
need to process Tracidor's death
and the strategic failure of the
mission.
It gives the narrative the
closure it needs before they get
thrown into the next sequence.
It's a strong structural fix.
So these three changes, slowing
down for the emotional
aftermath, framing the deception
as a high stakes performance,
and extending the physical
struggle of the retreat, they
all work together to amplify the
weight of these sessions.
They ensure failure doesn't just
happen, but that it leaves
lasting, visible scars on the
narrative and the characters.
It really elevates the entire
submission.
The story gains that needed
depth and resonance.
It forces the reader to sit with
the consequences rather than
just read about them.
Exactly.
So to summarize, we focused on
three critical areas to really
sharpen the narrative impact.
First, dedicate space to the
emotional fallout after
traumatic events.
Use that descriptive sensory
detail for moments of grief.
Second, exploit the dramatic
tension in the deception of is
Mark.
Frame that scene as a high
stakes, physically painful
performance.
Right.
And third, slow down the pacing
during the retreat from Mount
Gehacas to emphasize the
profound physical and
psychological cost of failure.
Turn the environment itself into
a grinding antagonist.
We really look forward to seeing
the revisions of these
compelling sessions.
Please feel free to send us your
next draft for another critique.
Welcome listener to the deep
dive.
We are plunging back into, well,
the perpetual gloom of Borovia.
It's a place where sanity is
really a luxury and survival
demands these constant, terrible
compromises.
It really does.
And today's sources, they're
from message dot TXT covering
sessions 24 and 25.
So that's from December 13th
through December 20th, 2025.
And these notes, they don't just
chronicle a journey, they
document a a really rapid moral
erosion under some intense,
intense duress.
Yeah, you said it.
These notes describe a period
of, I mean, unprecedented
volatility for the party.
We're going to see them making
packs for dark power, suffering
a just devastating loss on a
treacherous mountain.
And committing what might be
their most chilling betrayal yet
right out on the open Rd.
Exactly.
So our mission today is really
to track these rapidly shifting
goals.
They go from seeking ancient
power to, you know, political
infiltration.
And we need to analyze the
psychological and ethical cost
of just existing in Raven Loft.
So our surviving core group,
we've still got Jorhun Tenpenny,
the Halfling Beastmaster.
And Radley the human Eldridge
Knight, and Derman Cobain, the
elven arcane trickster.
But we have to acknowledge which
the the tragic vacuum left by
the recent death of Tracidor,
the half elf cleric of light,
His absence, I mean as both a
healer and kind of a moral
anchor.
It is felt immediately and
profoundly in these sessions.
Oh, absolutely.
And taking his place, at least
for now, is a new, very
pragmatic edition per land.
Good Shadow, A halfling monk.
The stakes have just never been
higher.
And the notes, they really force
us to ask a question.
At what point does the goal of
defeating Strad justify the
corruption you need to gain and
the power to do it?
And when does self preservation
just fully extinguish the
capacity for basic human
decency?
OK, let's unpack this by
starting in what seems like a
safe place where a pretty dark
secret is revealed right over
dinner.
Yeah, that's the perfect place
to start.
So this deep dive, it opens on a
brief, almost jarring moment of
peace.
The party has arrived at the
Wizards of Wine.
Right, the Vineyard estate.
It's protected by the Mardukov
family, which includes Danica
and Irwin, who you'll remember
had to flee all that political
chaos back in Valaki.
And they're all gathered for a
dinner celebration.
It's probably the first truly
peaceful moment they've had in
weeks.
And it's such a classic
narrative technique, isn't it?
You create this brief, warm
backdrop just so you can reveal
the darkness that's been lurking
underneath all along.
They're relaxing among allies.
They think they're safe, but the
moment is just shattered by a
simple observation that has
these profound implications in a
place like Borovia.
And that observation is.
The discovery that you're a
horn.
The Hafling casts no shadow.
The sources are so clear about
this they call him the
Shadowless Halfling.
Wow, for a place governed by the
dark powers and just saturated
with ancient evil, that is an
immediate glaring spiritual
anomaly.
You can't just ignore that.
Not at all.
And the group's suspicion is, I
mean, it's totally justified,
right?
Oh 100%.
In the established lore of
Ravenloft, losing your shadow is
never an accident.
It implies a critical detachment
from the mortal world, a
profound severance, or, and this
is the most common one, a
contract with one of the
dreadful vestiges.
The sentient ancient entities
imprisoned under the Amber
Temple.
Exactly the ones that grant
power in exchange for, you know,
a piece of your soul or your
identity.
But you're a horn.
He seems prepared for this.
He immediately admits his
purpose is total vengeance
against Stride for all the
misery and Raven Loft, and to
get the power he needed for this
one singular mission, he
acquired what he calls a missed
token.
And that token, he confirms,
demanded his shadow as payment.
It's such a complex trade off,
isn't it?
He sacrificed a piece of his
very essence for what seems like
a noble purpose, defeating the
ultimate evil of the land.
And the party, I mean, they're
exhausted by repeated failure,
so they're temporarily placated
by this.
They just accept the shadows
loss as the necessary cost of
competence.
Which raises A crucial question
right at the start.
Can power that's sourced from
the Land's own corruption truly
be used for salvation?
Does the source of that power
inevitably taint the mission, no
matter how noble the intent?
It almost feels like a bargain
he had to make to survive, you
know?
I think so.
In Borovia you can't fight the
devil with just pure intentions.
You need teeth.
Exactly.
And the power Eurohorn gets is
both magical and intensely
practical, which we see like
immediately, the very next
morning.
Yeah, that token seems to have
enhanced his deepest skill, his
connection to the natural world.
Speaking of his specific goals,
the next morning he goes on
what's detailed Less is a simple
search, and more is this
ancient, highly technical
ritual, the taming of a powerful
beast.
He's described as an expert
woodsman, but this feels like it
goes way beyond just tracking.
The notes really emphasize this
almost shamanistic process.
He leaves the winery in the pre
dawn hours tracking a specific
quarry and it's so detailed he
collects Tufts of hair, pieces
of tree bark where the prey
marked its territory.
So he's gathering reagents.
He is.
These organic components are
crucial.
He gathers a variety of local
herbs and then adds the tracking
evidence to them, creating this
bundle that's both bait and a
ritual component.
And he finds his target, a
magnificent, fierce Mountain
Lion perched high on a thick
branch.
And it's not happy to see him.
It's immediately territorial,
fully prepared to treat this
halfling as a, you know, a small
meal.
But you're a horn armed with his
deep knowledge and I think maybe
the subtle influence of that
Miss Token, he just refuses the
confrontation.
And what's fascinating here is
his use of these non aggressive
psychological tactics.
Right, instead of drawing a
weapon, he.
Performs a series of slow blinks
to calm the beast.
In the animal Kingdom, that's a
universal sign of trust, of non
threat, and it stops the
predator cold.
Mountain Lion.
It was tense, ready to pounce,
but now it just starts to pace
and aggression is replaced by
curiosity.
And then the ritual culminates.
Your horn rubs this wad of herbs
into his hands, infusing his own
scent with these powerful,
calming reagents.
Then he gently throws the rest
of bundle on the ground and just
backs away, letting the cat
approach on its own terms.
And the cat's reaction is just
transformative.
Apprehension gives way to this
overwhelming curiosity about the
scent.
It leaps down, sniffs it, and
then in this this amazing
display of submission, it just
flopped into the forest floor
and starts writhing in the
herbs.
The fight is over, the bond is
forming and the final physical
interaction, the cat rubbing its
face in the halflings palms and
then eventually just reclining
right on top of him as the dawn
comes up that solidifies this
mystical symbiotic bond.
And the result is immediate.
Your horn instantly mounts his
new companion, this formidable
Wildcat, and they return to the
winery together.
He's gone from a vulnerable man
to a Beastmaster with a loyal,
incredibly powerful ally.
And that's critical context.
That Mountain Lion isn't just a
pet, it's a force multiplier and
apex predator bound to your
horn.
This bond gives them a critical
advantage they will need
immediately as they turn their
attention to the highest, most
dangerous point in the entire
valley.
With your horn newly empowered,
the party reaffirms their goal
over breakfast.
They have to ascend Mount
Gawkies to find the Amber
Temple.
A location foretold in Madame
Eva's card reading, and it's
reputed to be this Nexus of
ancient forbidden power.
Really the only potential source
of strength they think is
capable of challenging Strawd.
The quest for the Amber Temple,
it feels like a desperate play
for competence.
They know they're outmatched and
they need that ancient knowledge
or some powerful artifact to
close the gap.
But even as they commit to this
dangerous path, we see just how
fragile their alliances are.
That's right, When the
adventurers get back on the
Spellish road and turn toward
the mountain, the druid Riven
Thal, who they had rescued and
traveled with for a while.
He just thanks them and
unceremoniously departs.
That phrase unceremoniously
departs.
It's so significant it just
underlines this relentless theme
of self-interest in Barovia.
There's no sentimentality, no
discussion of strategy, just a
quick severing of ties.
Riven Thal clearly weigh the
danger of the Amber Temple
against the benefit and just
decided the risk was too great.
Yeah, and the party's
immediately reminded that in
this land, survival always
supersedes loyalty.
Every alliance is temporary.
So the remaining group, they
turn S onto a gravel road and
the climb begins immediately.
The notes detail this rapid,
punishing intensification of the
conditions.
Oh yeah, they're hit with
patches of snow.
The temperature just sinks
drastically and they have to
deal with this gusting, whipping
wind.
The road becomes a treacherous
switch back.
Sheer Cliff on one side, deadly
drop on the other.
It's an immediate physical
grind.
They're transitioning from the
relative safety of the valley
floor to a profoundly hostile
environment, both physically and
magically.
The cold itself becomes this
constant grinding enemy before
they even meet a single monster.
And their arduous ascent is
eventually blocked by this
really imposing structure, a
defensive wall and a gatehouse
that just cuts off the path to
the higher reaches of the
mountain.
This architecture is pure dark
spectacle.
It's designed to repel.
We're talking 20 foot high walls
crowned by a gay house that's 10
feet higher than that.
The size alone is intimidating.
And then on top you have two
colossal statues that look like
ominous vultures and the wall
itself is lined with these tall
stone spikes.
Just screams do not enter.
And the most immediate,
terrifying obstacle is the
passage itself.
The portcullis is dropped, and
just beyond it a colossal wall
of green flame is burning
furiously.
This isn't it's just a fire.
This is clearly powerful lethal
magic, possibly infernal.
And their immediate response is
just perfectly pragmatic.
It's exactly how survivors
operate.
They stick an arrow into the
flames.
And it instantly bursts into.
Fire confirming it's real, not
an illusion.
Very dangerous energy.
They can't just pass through it.
This forces them into a
difficult decision, which is
compounded by the rapidly
deteriorating weather.
Their solution requires
Eurohorn's new Beast companion.
Despite the mountain lion's
reluctance to climb sheer rock,
Eurohorn commands it to scramble
up the near vertical surface of
the Cliff face right next to the
gate.
And once the cat is at the top,
Eurohorn uses one of the walls
defensive spikes as a makeshift
snubbing post and throws a rope
down to the party below.
It becomes this exhaustive,
protracted effort to haul the
entire party, including Radley
and Derriman, over that 20 foot
wall.
And this is a critical detail.
They are physically draining
themselves before the inevitable
confrontation.
They're spending vital energy
reserves that they're going to
need for the battle to come.
Once they're over, their
thoughts immediately turn to
survival against the elements.
They spot a white stone guard
tower nearby, and they're just
desperately speculating about
shelter.
The temperature is sinking
toward truly lethal levels,
threatening to end their quest
not by monster but by
hyperdermia.
But the mountain, it had other
plants.
Their desperate musings on
shelter are just interrupted by
this horrifying piercing sound
and unearthly screeching that
cuts right through the howling
wind.
Looking back, they realized the
two enormous vulture like
statues atop the gatehouse are
no longer statues.
They're animated, yeah.
The terror of the surprise
attack is multiplied by the
reveal that they are facing
something far worse than
standard undead.
These creatures flap down,
landing right in the middle of
the party.
And the notes confirm their
demonic nature.
They're nearly 10 feet tall,
terrifying 15 foot wingspan, and
they emit this palpable,
stinking miasma of fitted decay.
They are later identified as
Rocks, powerful demons from the
Abyss.
This is a tactical nightmare.
These aren't just brute force
combatants.
Rocks are specifically designed
to incapacitate groups to
neutralize defenses and control.
Absolutely.
Let's let's dissect their brutal
methodology.
They attack on multiple fronts
at the same time.
First, they periodically unleash
this cloud of spores designed to
cause uncontrollable wretching
and convulsions.
So a crippling physical attack
that takes targets out of the
fight immediately.
Immediately and second they
deploy these deafening magical
screams that assault the mind
and stun anyone who use the It's
a perfect 1-2 punch.
Incapacitate the body with
spores.
Incapacitate the will with the
scream.
And while the party is
convulsing or stunned, the rocks
use their primary physical
attack.
Running with these great scythe
like claws, the party's typical
tactics are just thrown into
chaos.
The tactical dynamics here are
really revealing.
Dermont the Arcane Trickster.
He relies on stealth and
opportunity.
He only engages when enemies are
distracted, which is a difficult
task when everyone is stunned or
retching.
And Radley the Eldritch Knight.
He's forced to alternate wildly
between his sword, offensive
magic like Fire Bolt, and then
necessary defense with his
shield spell.
But without a dedicated healer
to remove the conditions, the
spores and the screams are just
deadly.
You're a horn mounted on his
great cat wisely avoids the
epicenter of the melee.
He uses the cat's mobility to
shoot arrows while he's trying
to scout the tower, and he finds
the door is barred from within,
which is emphasizes their
isolation.
And the lack of a cleric, the
lack of Tracidor, is suddenly
and tragically magnified the
Rock's ability to 'cause these
widespread, debilitating
conditions, it requires instant
healing and counter magic, which
Tracksador used to provide.
And because he was the most
visible source of light, of life
and healing in this dark land,
the notes state, he was the one
hardest pressed by the demons.
He falls under the barrage of
claws and spores, slowly
bleeding out amid the carnage
before the demons just slay him
completely.
It's a devastating, irreversible
blow.
Tracidor was the moral compass,
the source of restoration, and
now he is simply gone.
It confirms the brutal cost of
even attempting to reach the
Amber Temple.
So with him dead and the
remaining members exhausted,
wounded and spent their magical
resources, the immediate
pragmatic decision is made.
The quest is abandoned.
They cannot continue upward.
This moment, it feels like the
true turning point of this whole
deep dive.
The dream of the Amber Temple,
the hope for ancient power, is
deferred by a violent death.
It's a harsh reminder that the
environment of Borovia will
punish overreach relentlessly.
They literally drag their bodies
over that wall only to realize
they didn't have the strength to
survive the gatekeeper.
The first step after that brutal
battle is a necessity dictated
by the cold.
They have to dispose of their
fallen friend Traxidor, and the
chosen method is profoundly
unsettling.
Yeah, it really is.
At the slink of Pass Gate, the
party honors their fallen cleric
by creating his body in that
mysterious wall of green flames
that blocks the passage.
It's a shocking symbolic act.
They're using the Infernal
Barrier that ended their quest
to dispose of the body of their
Cleric of Light.
Just think about the
psychological toll of that using
an evil, seemingly unholy energy
source to perform a rite of
passage for a virtuous
companion.
It just underscores the utter
desperation and the blurring of
moral lines that is now standard
operating procedure for this
group.
After this grim closure, they
turn back to the White Tower for
shelter.
Radley boosts your horn up to
the second story window, and the
halfling once again slips past
the iron bars.
He's their scout and their key.
Your horn reports back on the
strange empty interior.
He then heads to the parapets,
finding 10 tall golden statues
of female Knights, clearly
figures of defense or
dedication.
And ominously, several chainmail
clad skeletons half buried in
the snow.
Which suggests that many have
tried and failed to hold or pass
this point before them.
He finds nothing of value on the
frozen skeletons and actually
unbarring the door.
They discover the tower, while
it's structurally sound, is
useless for true rest.
It has a hearth, but no fuel.
They realize they cannot survive
the night there.
So after taking only a single
hour to patch their wounds and
catch their breath from the rock
assault, they choose immediate
descent.
This whole sequence is a master
class in prioritization.
They are not heroes seeking
glory.
They are survivalist,
prioritizing warmth and safety
over recovery or exploration.
They climb back over their ropes
and begin the long, exhausting
descent down Mount Gakis.
Once they hit the Mains Failage
Rd., they choose the village of
Barovia as their next objective.
Get warm, purchase new equipment
to replace what they lost on the
mountain.
But as they approach the
Western.
Gates of Barovia.
They intercept a highly
disturbing convoy, and this is
the critical.
Juncture where the narrative
shifts from physical survival to
profound moral failure.
They catch up to travelers from
Valaki, town guards they
recognize, and about a half
dozen villagers who are laboring
to push a heavy cart up the
steep Rd. toward Castle
Ravenloft.
And the carts?
Terrifying.
Contents are immediately visible
inside.
A young woman is bound to posts,
clearly dressed for a ritual
sacrifice.
She's in white, adorned with
mountain flowers, but her beauty
is just.
Overshadowed by her terror, her
countenance is fearful.
Her wrists are raw from
desperate attempts to free
herself.
They realize instantly this is a
victim being delivered
distraught.
Their initial reaction is.
Pure instinctive heroism.
They immediately decide to
ambush the guards and free the
maiden before the group reaches
the castle, and the execution is
swift and clinical.
Expert arrow shots and a magical
fireball dispatch the guards
instantly before the villagers
or the.
Maiden can even fully process
what's happening, but the
immediate success?
Is followed by a catastrophic
failure of execution and
judgment.
Seeing the guards killed, the
villagers instantly flee,
scattering into the woods.
Critically, the cart is left.
Unattended on the steep
ascending Sailage Rd. gravity
immediately takes hold and the
cart begins to roll backwards,
uncontrolled, picking up
devastating speed.
It's just a devastating
sequence.
Your horn and Dermont both try
to catch the carts frame as it
rockets past them, but their
hands slip on the accelerating
wood.
They just don't have the mass or
the leverage to stop it and the
speeding card approaches.
Radley, the party's Herculean
and fighter, the man who has
stood toe to toe with demons and
survived.
This is the moment where
physical competence meets
psychological collapse, the
notes stated so.
Clearly, Radley opts to step
aside and let it rumble past.
Here is where the weight of the.
Last 48 hours just crushes the
hero.
Why did he step aside?
We have to analyze this beyond a
simple plot device.
Radley is physically capable of
stopping or at least slowing
that cart, but he's mentally
spent.
He just watched his friend.
Die was nearly killed by demons,
cremated his comrade and
infernal fire that choice.
To let the cart go.
It could be read as calculated
indifference, a momentary triage
where he prioritizes his own
safety over a high risk, low
percentage chance of saving a
stranger.
Or, and this is maybe more
psychologically devastating,
it's a trauma response, a moment
where the accumulated horror
just paralyzed his will to act.
And the consequence is.
Horrific.
The Maidi shrieks in terror as
the cart gains impossible speed.
It flies over the embanked, then
at a sharp bend in the road, is
dashed violently against Stony
outcroppings and it just
disintegrates into splinters,
the note stated with brutal.
Clarity the maidens crushed
corpse lies splayed amid the
wreckage and this next detail
is.
Arguably the most brutal of the
entire deep dive.
After briefly viewing the
carnage, the crushed body, the
shattered wood, the party simply
turn and continue on their way.
No discussion?
No.
Grief, no attempt to bury the
body, no moment of recognition
that their heroic impulse
resulted in an agonizing,
unnecessary death.
This scene perfectly
encapsulates.
The brutalizing nature of their
environment.
They have achieved a level of
emotional bankruptcy where an
innocent, agonizing death
directly caused by their actions
is met with cold dismissal.
They have officially prioritized
their immediate goal of buying
equipment over the life they
just tried and failed to save.
Their moral capacity is.
Completely eroded under the
pressure of Borovia, so the
party enters the village.
Of Borovia under the cover of
night, carrying this immense
psychological weight.
Traxidor's death.
The Cart Maiden's fate, Radley
in particular must be dealing
with immense Survivor's Guild,
having lost Vallanaire and now
Tracidor, his original comrades
that internal stress.
It has to find an outlet, and it
manifests immediately in his
choices.
First they had to the only
Tavern, the blood of the Vine,
and the atmosphere there is just
one of profound, resigned
desolation.
The Sullen Barman, Eric.
Is serving only water.
Even the small, temporary
comfort of wine is denied to the
desperate inhabitants of
Borovia.
It's in this setting they find
a.
Small temporary reprieve.
They meet Pearlman Good Shadow,
the only other halfling scene in
the village of Borovia.
He's a monk, and after hearing
the dangers the party faces and
likely recognizing the dangers
in the village itself, Pearlman
agrees to join forces.
So they quickly patched the.
Manpower gap left by Traxidor
But while this new alliance is.
Forming Radley is drawn away.
Mirabelle of Estani proprietor
recognizes him She approaches
him in this sultry fashion,
making unsubtle references to
his recently missing companions.
Instead of offering grief, she.
Offers him an alternative
distraction to the barrenness of
the village and Radley eagerly.
Accepts this eldritch knight is
seeking a desperate temporary
escape.
He agrees to spend the evening
with Mirabelle and her sisters
Alenka and Sorvino.
This immediate embrace of
hedonism is a classic trauma
coping mechanism, a desperate
attempt to numb the pain and
psychological horror of the last
few days through indulgence.
That pursuit of a.
Rate Desperate Distraction
stands in stark contrast to what
the remaining trio experiences.
You're a horn.
Derrman and Purlen head out to
find shelter, and they run into
one of Barovia's most insidious
threats.
The old hag Morganta, right?
She's pushing her cart.
Slyly trying to sell her
addictive dream pastries for a
single gold coin, the trio ever.
Distrustful, they brusquely
refuse her wares.
But Morganta, completely
unfazed, delivers this chilling
line.
She insists someone else will
buy them as she never returns
home with unsold pies.
And that statement is so
critical.
It reinforces the ubiquitous
nature of this invisible,
insidious evil that grips the
populace.
While Radley is escaping his
trauma through self medicating
hedonism, the rest of the town
is caught in the subtle,
pervasive addiction that
literally preys on their dreams.
Both choices just reflect the.
Profound misery that Barovia
inflicts.
So the trio finds an abandoned
house, barricades themselves
inside, and settles down for a
restless night while Radley is
elsewhere.
Day 19 begins with Radley.
Rejoining the group, the notes
describe him as disheveled and
wearing a dopey expression,
clearly showing the physical
signs of his night of deep,
desperate indulgence, and the
contrast is immediate.
The eldritch night, smelling of
drink and perfume, is instantly
thrust into this urgent
political and emotional
confrontation.
They go immediately to the Burr
Master's Manor to seek out IS
Mark, who has taken up his late
father's mantle.
IS Mark opens the door.
But his demeanor is highly
suspicious.
He demands to know who these
three strangers are.
He last saw Radley with Tracidor
and Valenaire, and his paranoia
is taken to.
An extreme degree.
Without warning, Ismark abruptly
splashes the entire party with a
bucket of water, immediately
explaining it was holy.
Wire and he had to ensure they
were not undead.
Spawn of Strawd.
This is an act of welcoming.
It's a necessity born of the
acute paranoia that infects
every resident of Barovia.
So once they're soggly inside.
The conversation immediately
turns frantic.
Ismark asks urgently about his
sister.
Irena, Radley and Derman relay
the tale of the Vampire spawns
attack on Valaki 8 days prior
and Ismark is frantic.
He's clearly received little to
no accurate news in the Valley,
and this is the moment of moral
collapse.
Ismark is desperate for truth
and the party, seeing an
opportunity for self
preservation, commits a highly
strategic deception they
intentionally conceal.
Several critical, damning facts
from Ismark.
Let's break down the layers of
this.
Betrayal.
They omit that Saint Andrew's
church was burned to the ground
and the priest was killed in the
chaos.
They conceal the terrible truth.
That Straud had demanded Irena
from the townsfolk, and most
damningly, they failed to
mention that the terrified mob
had literally pulled Irena from
the Blue Water Inn and
surrendered her to the vampire
Lord.
Instead, they offer a carefully.
Constructed half truth, they say
they had merely escorted her to
the church for safety and then
left town to seek refuge at the
Wizards of Wine.
They're protecting their own
reputation and avoiding
confessing the failure that led
to Irene's capture.
It's a necessary move.
To secure is mark as an ally as
a shield as they try to re enter
of Alaki and is mark distraught.
By the incomplete information
insists they must leave
immediately to save his sister.
The party agrees with the
suspicious haste, not for
altruistic reasons, but because
they desperately need to
retrieve their lost Amulet of
Ravenkind from the new Burgo
Master.
Lady Washer is Mark just dashes
out.
Sword girded, urging Aced.
Think about the depth of this.
Betrayal.
They are manipulating their
friends Grief and dedication,
marching him straight into a
town they know is under the
control of a dark cultist
without giving him the vital
life saving context that his
sister is already likely
compromised and that the
townspeople themselves.
Are responsible for her capture.
They're using him as a pawn to.
Retrieve a necessary artifact.
It's.
It's cold, so is.
Mark is.
Driven by the singular purpose,
he's marching like a possessed
man back towards Balaki.
He barely even registers the
marks near the western gates of
Barovia, where the Cartmaiden
sacrifice turned into tragedy.
His focus is entirely on Irena,
on the journey, the party.
Fills him in on the political
chaos, the deposition of Baron
Vargas Volakovich and the
seizure of the title of
burgomaster by Lady Walker and
Ismark offers.
A crucial piece of lore.
Here he shares that the Walker
family is very old in Barovia,
dating back to before Straud
even arrived in the Valley.
That's a fascinating detail,
isn't?
It it suggests that Walker isn't
just some political climber.
She might represent a deeper,
older corruption in Barovia,
perhaps a rival power structure
or a collaborator with something
far more ancient than Stride
himself.
It raises the stakes.
Significantly, they come up with
a plan.
Since Radley, your Horn and
Derriman are fugitives, is Mark
and Pearlman, the strangers will
try to convince the guards to
open the gate under the pretext
of is Mark's urgent mission
setting up an ambush.
But watch your security.
Is immediately apparent.
The ruse fails instantly.
The guards loyal to the new
Burgamaster are fiercely
suspicious and totally
unimpressed by IS Mark's minor
status.
They insist on strict.
Non negotiable orders not to
allow strangers in,
belligerently demanding that is
Mark and Pearlman leave
immediately.
This confirms 2 things.
One, the party is still very
much wanted fugitives in balaki
and two, Lady Watchers regime is
far more tightly controlled and
ruthlessly pragmatic than the
previous baron's chaotic
delusional rule.
A direct confrontation at the
gate is just impossible, so
retreating to.
Concealment.
The party realizes the gates are
the only heavily garrisoned
area.
They move northward to a
secluded section of the city
wall, deciding to use stealth
and agility to bypass the
guards.
They recognize the immense.
Risk involved, though.
They vividly recall their last
encounter with Lady Watcher,
where her personal bodyguard of
devils required the intervention
of Rudolf Van Richten to save
them.
They are infiltrating a known
layer of infernal power, and
they have no cleric to heal them
this time.
They Sprint toward the wall.
Waiting for the momentary cover
of the ever present mist to
obscure a single century's
vision and the ascent is
predictably a mixed bag of grace
and awkwardness.
The notes describe the climb.
Humorously, they say, some glide
over easily, while others
struggle in a manner resembling
a monkey trying to fuck a
football.
That small injection of humor.
Is important.
I think it's a necessary stress
relief for a party under
incredible strain.
It is but.
Regardless of their grace, they
all make it over, dashing
immediately for the concealment
of the houses within the town.
Their target is clear.
Lady Watchers home, which they
correctly identify as the keeper
of all the secrets in the town,
and they decide the safest, most
discreet entry point is the
basement root cellar.
They successfully descend.
Into this vacant root cellar
which has a dirt floor.
But as they move the tell tale
sound of crumbling dirt heralds
an ambush. 8 animated skeletons
claw their way violently from
the earth to menace the party.
This is Washers defense.
System for subterranean entry
but what's fascinating here is
how this fight contrasts with
the traumatic battle against the
rocks this confrontation serves
as a powerful demonstration of
the party's profound evolution
as combatants yeah this
highlights their.
Transformation from clumsy
adventurers to hardened, lethal
survivors.
Radley, who began as a simple
man at arms, has been forged in
the Crucible of weeks of combat
into a ruthless eldritch knight.
Proficiently combining spells
and swordplay, they're better
equipped.
Ruthlessly coordinated and just
far more efficient, the
adventurers effortlessly cut and
smashed through them what would
have been a terrifying.
Resource draining battle just
weeks ago is now a little more
than maintenance work.
The fight is over almost before
it begins, demonstrating their
sheer increase in physical
competence.
Even if their moral compasses,
you know, shattered, they are
now just better.
At survival after dispatching
the skeletons.
They start searching the room
and note a crucial environmental
clue.
If you foot traffic, the wear
pattern in the dirt floor runs
heavily from the exterior door
to a specific far wall, which
suggests the pathway used.
Often by something or someone
significant to watchers
operations investigating the
wall they.
Apply pressure and find it
easily spins on a fulcrum
revealing a secret chamber
beyond this is the moment they
bypass all her overt security
and breach watchers, true
private operations and the
disturbing contents.
Are laid bare in the empty room,
5 chairs surrounding A carefully
drawn pentagram on the floor.
This disturbing revelation.
Immediately confirms the nature
of Lady Washer's power base.
The pentagram is the
unmistakable sign of infernal or
demonic ritual and the presence
of five chairs.
Is also significant.
It suggests a coven or a
dedicated ritual group, maybe
the five people required for
specific packs or summoning
rights.
This discovery reinforces.
Why she had a bodyguard of
devils when they last met.
Her Watcher's not just a
political schemer.
She is an active participant in
dark rights, ruling Valaki by
Infernal contract.
This confirms the immense
danger.
The party is in, especially
since they are now standing
literally beneath the home of a
dark worshipper whose primary
objective is to stop anyone who
threatens Strawd.
They have infiltrated the layer.
Of a power structure that may
even predate the Dark Lord
himself.
They came to steal an amulet,
but they have stumbled upon the
very source of corruption in the
new Valaki regime.
We have completed a deep.
Dive into two turbulent sessions
listener tracking a party that
has evolved from desperate
adventurers into, well, ruthless
survivalists.
It's quite a transformation we.
Witnessed your horns profound
sacrifice of his shadow for a
mystical bond.
The brutal failure and cost of
Tracidor's life on Mount Caucus
and the shocking moral.
Collapse on the Spalich Rd.
culminating in the cold,
immediate dismissal of the
Cartmaidens agonized death.
The central themes are just so.
Clear The pursuit of power
necessitates compromise.
The price of the Mist token was
your horns essence.
The price of the Amber Temple
quest was Traxidor's life and
the price of their rush to.
Borovia was the life of an
innocent they failed to save.
Their emotional and ethical
compass is now severely
compromised.
They are highly efficient but
increasingly callous.
Yeah, and they've re entered.
Valaki, under the guise of
Ismarks grief, hiding the
crushing truth of Irena's
capture.
They are now literally beneath
the home of Lady Walker, a woman
whose operations clearly
involved the ritualistic worship
of dark powers, proven by that
pentagram chamber.
This raises a final provocative.
Thought for you to consider as
they move forward.
They are now expert survivors in
a land designed to break them.
So given the terrible things
they have.
Seen and done using infernal
fire for cremation, their
indifference to human life and
the tactical deception of their
friend is Mark.
Are they still seeking to save
the land of Barovia, or have
they simply become the most
capable, morally hollow
creatures within its misery?
And what price ultimately?
Will they pay when Lady Watcher
inevitably realizes they have
uncovered the dark nature of the
power she is truly serving in
that pentagram room?
This is the brief on.
Dungeons and Dragons Sessions 24
and 25.
All right, so this story arc
takes the party way deeper into
Borovia, that gloomy vampire
ruled land.
And we're talking about a huge
character moment.
I absolutely brutal fight on a
frozen mountain and the start of
a really dangerous political
conspiracy.
First up, let's talk about the
beastmaster Yurihorn Tenpenny to
get his hands on a powerful mist
token for his revenge quest.
He paid a chilling price.
He's now completely shadowless,
but Even so, he managed to form
this incredible bond with a
Mountain Lion, using an ancient
ritual of slow blinks and herbs
to mystically seal their
partnership.
Honestly, this new ally might be
the only thing that keeps him
alive, but that high point just
didn't last.
Second, we have the battle on
Mount Galacus.
The party was climbing toward
the legendary Amber Temple, a
place of immense power, when a
fortified gatehouse blocked
their path.
And the guards 2 giant vulture
statues that came to life as
rocks.
You know, powerful winged
demons.
The fight was desperate,
exhausting, and in the end the
group suffered a terrible loss.
Their cleric, Tracidor, was
killed.
The survivors had no choice but
to retreat, cremating their
friend in some mysterious green
flames before abandoning the
quest.
So after that disaster, they
descended the mountain,
recruited a new companion, a
halfling monk named Pearland
Good Shadow, and shifted their
focus.
Finally, a dangerous
infiltration.
They successfully sneak into the
home of the new Burger Master or
village leader, Lady Walker.
Down in the basement, they
destroy 8 animated skeletons and
then find a secret chamber.
And what's inside is chilling 5
chairs surrounding a massive
pentagram.
Pretty much confirming the new
leadership is tied to some kind
of deadly cult.
So what we're seeing is a tragic
mix of profound personal
moments, the brutal cost of
challenging evil in Borovia, and
clear signs of a terrifying
conspiracy just beginning to
unfold.
Welcome to the debate.
We are returning today to the
the unforgiving landscape of
Borovia, focusing on a really
pivotal moment for the halfling
Beastmaster Yuri Horn Tenpenny
right during sessions. 24 and 25
and this is where he's driven by
this deep need for revenge
against Strad and well, he has
to make an ultimate choice.
He does.
He has to pay a.
Metaphysical Price He sacrifices
his own shadow to get a Mist
token, this artifact that's
supposed to aid his cause.
And the question we're wrestling
with today is, is both practical
and deeply existential.
Does Yuri Horn's calculated
sacrifice of his shadow
represent a justified strategic
commitment, something vital for
operating in Barovia?
Or does it signify A profound,
compromising existential cost
that fundamentally undermines
his ability to achieve his
goals?
Frame it.
I mean, we are.
Dissecting the high cost of what
some might call necessary
cruelty.
And I firmly argue this
transaction constitutes an
irreversible existential debt.
The moment your horn lost his
shadow, he he compromised his
very nature.
In the context of Ravenloft,
this isn't just poetic, it's a
visible spiritual abnormality
that marks him.
And I would argue this was.
Perhaps the most rational choice
he could have made given his
mission.
His actions weren't rash.
They were rooted in in explicit
strategic necessity.
He needed power, and he needed
it now.
Sure, he stated clearly.
His mission?
Required the Mist token and the
shadow was simply the currency.
And we can't overlook the
immediate tangible utility this
price yielded.
The very next morning, he
successfully uses that token to
bond with an Apex Mountain Lion.
This cat becomes an essential
mission critical resource.
The commitment yielded immediate
results and I acknowledge the.
Impressiveness of that bond I
do.
The power it conferred is
undeniable.
However, I don't frame it as a
successful trade, but as a
Faustian bargain with immediate
damning consequences.
The loss of a shadow, especially
in these lands, is not a simple
transactional cost.
It is a visible liability and we
have proof during.
The celebration at the.
Wizards of Wine, the Martikoff
family who are so tied to the
land they noticed their
suspicion was immediate, and it
required Yuri Horn to, you know,
concoct A stressful explanation
on the fly to placate one of the
few benevolent factions in all
of Barovia.
The cost wasn't abstract to all,
it was a brand and he managed
that liability.
Perfectly, didn't he?
The fact that he was able to
provide a convincing explanation
and move on just shows his
commitment was strong enough to
manage that social friction.
But more importantly, let's
focus on the return on
investment.
The bonded Mountain Lion proved
its worth instantly when they
reached Salanka Pass.
The party's ascent to the Amber
Temple was stopped cold by a
formidable defensive structure.
We're talking a 20 foot high
wall, a portcullis, wicked
spikes and a perpetual wall of
green flame.
I mean, this thing was a
showstopper, a military barrier.
The cat able to scramble the
near vertical Cliff face
provided the vital bypass that
demonstrated immediate strategic
utility.
It moves the party from absolute
deadlock to progress.
That to me, outweighs the
abstract metaphysical cost.
My concern?
Is that we're prioritizing a
temporary means over the
inherent cost of those means.
Your record pays this heavy
known existential cost a piece
of itself for a goal.
The miss token who specific long
term utility against Strad is,
well, it's undefined.
He made a permanent sacrifice
based on a generalized promise.
The short term benefit of
climbing a wall, while useful
for that one afternoon, just
doesn't seem to justify the
potential for long term
spiritual danger to the Marta
cops.
Being shadowless implies you're
tainted.
Maybe you made a pact.
Or worse, you've already fallen
prey to Strad.
It's a vulnerability that
requires constant mental energy
to conceal.
Let's delve into that a bit.
More deeply, the strategic gain
versus this existential
vulnerability.
I can see the shadows and
metaphysical cost.
But the Salanka Pass was an
equally potent physical
representation of Barovia's
opposition.
We are talking about overcoming
A literal fortress.
The Mountain Lion bond enabled
the breach of an obstacle that
could have cost the party weeks
or forced an immensely costly
frontal assault.
The ability to bypass that is
not a minor footnote.
It is a direct, measurable
strategic return.
I understand the.
Tactical necessity of bypassing
the gate?
I do, but the cause compromises
Yuri Horn's identity in a way
that risks catastrophic exposure
later on.
In Barovia, the shadow is often
seen as a tangible piece of the
soul.
Losing it isn't just losing your
shade, it is fundamentally
diminishing your essence.
This unnatural state.
It makes him a magnetic target.
If he later interacts with
genuinely good entities.
That shadowless state won't just
result in suspicion, it could
result in automatic hostility.
And what about the dark powers
themselves?
They demanded the price.
Do we really believe the entity
that took his shadow no longer
retained some kind of claim, a
subtle connection to him?
He is now carrying a
vulnerability that only benefits
the enemy.
The entity retains a.
Claim, yes, but Yurihorn
consciously accepted that to
operate against Straud, one must
accept that the conventional
rules of morality, of light and
shadow, they are suspended.
He traded a potential future
spiritual complication for
immediate tangible power.
If he had waited, they might
have been trapped at Salinka
Pass indefinitely.
The fact that the CAT allowed
them to continue their primary
mission proves the decision was
sound in the immediate tactical
sense.
But this leads perfectly.
Into our second point, the
nature of the mission and the
consequence.
I'm sorry, I just don't buy that
the Miss token was truly
necessary to achieve the
Mountain Lion bot.
The source material details Yuri
Horn, an expert woodsman
tracking the predator
meticulously.
He gathers specific herbs, the
Nights bloom and the whisper
leaf and Tufts of the cat's own
fur.
He was performing this master
work of primal communion.
He was already 90% of the way.
They're using his skill and that
90% was.
Insufficient.
Exactly.
He paid an immense existential
price for an artifact that
simply facilitated the final 10%
of the bond.
Was the Mist token truly
necessary, or did he just take a
shortcut out of impatience?
A shortcut that left him
permanently diminished when
patience and skill might have
achieved the same result?
Without the sacrifice, he could
have returned the next day.
This suggests the shadow loss
was an avoidable, extravagant
cost.
That's an interesting point.
Though I would frame it
differently, you're looking at
the bond as a natural expertise
challenge.
I see it as a political
challenge within Borovia.
The MISS token represents the
necessary step past the limits
of conventional expertise when
facing a foe like Strawd.
Pure expertise is not enough
there.
You need the extraordinary, the
unnatural, to fight an unnatural
enemy.
The token ensured the bond was
not merely one of respect, but a
bond of absolute command.
This let the cat perform feats
like that near vertical climb
under fire that a naturally
befriended beast might refuse.
He accelerated his power curve
precisely because time was a
luxury they did not have.
He traded A theoretical moral
purity for immediate
consolidated actionable power.
That is a tactical win.
But that actionable power?
Came packaged with a compromise
moral framework.
This commitment to necessary
brutality is evident later,
isn't it?
We see this shift in the group
when they encounter the fatally
injured maiden who fell with our
cart.
The party, newly hardened by
this philosophy, made the
callous decision to abandon her.
They just continue on their way.
The Shadow Law set the stage for
this new brutalized morality.
But this is where the commitment
breaks down.
I would say it's the.
Ultimate expression of the
tactical mindset required to win
in Barovia.
The sacrifice of the shadow
prepared him and the party
psychologically for the
ruthlessness the survival
demands.
They couldn't save her, and
spending time on it would have
risked the entire mission.
They stayed focused, and yet
this.
Focus.
This hardening, this existential
sacrifice, it all failed.
This brings us to the most
crushing evidence against the
strategy, the ultimate failure
at Salenka Pass.
Despite the utility of the cat,
and despite Udir Horn's
hardening, shortly after this
transformation, they suffered A
devastating loss.
Tracidor was slain by the
Abyssal of Rocks that appeared.
The party was so defeated, so
spent, that they abandoned the
mission to the Amber Temple
entirely.
They were treated back down the
mountain.
The existential sacrifice did
not guarantee mission success.
Instead, it preceded A profound
tactical failure and retreat.
I would argue that the mission.
Failed due to the sheer
unforeseen power of the rocks,
not because of Yuri Horn's
commitment.
He secured the means to access
the temple.
The sudden, devastating
intervention of Abyssal demons
derailed the plan.
The means were sound.
The execution was excellent.
The external circumstances were
simply overwhelming.
To claim that losing a shadow
somehow invited the rocks is
speculative.
I think it's more than.
Speculative.
It's a question of alignment.
The rocks, being abyssal, are
fundamentally antithetical to
the normal Borovian forces.
The party had made this extreme
sacrifice within the Borovian
framework to gain an advantage,
yet when the ultimate test
arrived, it came not from
Borovia's typical horrors, but
from an outside, purely
destructive planer force.
Did oriole horns compromise his
spiritual branding?
Make him magnetically attractive
to all forms of darkness.
The fact that they gained this
power and immediately suffered A
shattering mission ending loss
suggests the spiritual scales
were tipped decisively against
them by the cost they paid.
The correlation between.
The sacrifice and the rock
attack is circumstantial at
best.
We have to acknowledge that
Traxadora's death was a crushing
blow, an event that would
necessitate retreat regardless
of whether Yurihorn had a shadow
or not.
The decision to retreat was a
functional necessity, not a
reflection of the commitments
failure.
The Beastmaster commitment
provided the path.
He did not guarantee immortality
against abyssal forces, but the
compromise remains a.
Ticking clock Yuri Horn is now
permanently diminished.
His vulnerability isn't hidden,
it's visibly apparent to any
entity sensitive to the flow of
souls and darkness.
This vulnerability defines his
future interactions in Barovia.
Whether the mission progresses
today or a year from now.
You paid a permanent cost for a
temporary fleeting advantage
that resulted only in failure
and profound loss.
That is the definition of a bad
bargain.
Look your.
Corn made a calculated,
necessary commitment.
He exchanged an abstract
existential state, a shadow for
concrete, immediate power
required to challenge Straud.
The evidence of the wall climb
shows the strategic merit of the
sacrifice.
Even if the overall mission was
later stalled by the devastating
reality of combat.
The commitment was correct.
The ensuing combat was tragic,
and while the resulting beast.
Bond was undeniably useful for
that specific task.
The cost of losing the shadow
represents A corrupting debt
that compromises your corn's
essence.
In the end, this kind of
existential compromise it rarely
results in a net gain,
especially when the overall
strategy that necessitated it
still LED directly to profound
loss, exhaustion, and the forced
abandonment of the mission.
The trade was fundamentally
unequal.
The dilemma remains.
Stark for anyone trying to
operate within the extreme
brutality of Borovia, does the
pursuit of absolute good, or in
this case absolute revenge,
justify trading foundational
aspects of the self for fleeting
tactical gains?
And the question for our
listeners?
When confronting an enemy like
Strad is whether any cost, even
one that diminishes the soul,
can ever truly lead to victory,
or if it simply makes you a more
potent instrument for the very
darkness you aim to conquer.
We still have much more to
explore in the consequences of
this.
Always a pleasure to analyze.
The true cost of power in
Borovia.